>>> YOU CAN GO RIGHT IN.
>> HEY THERE, YOU MUST BE
DONALD.
>> HONOR TO MEET YOU,
MR. FOSTER.
>> PLEASE, MR. FOSTER WAS MY
FATHER.
CALL ME MR. FOSTER JUNIOR.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, IN-PERSON JOB
INTERVIEWS -- PRETTY RARE THESE
DAYS.
>> HERE AT MIXED MARTIAL MEDIA
WE DON'T EXACTLY PLAY BY THE
RULES.
BUT I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF
THAT.
>> I WAS VERY INTRIGUED BY YOUR
COMPANY.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF AN AD AGENCY
THAT WORKS ON SPEC.
SO YOU MAKE ADS FOR COMPANIES
THAT DIDN'T HIRE YOU TO MAKE
ADS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SOUNDS LIKE A TERRIBLE BUSINESS
MODEL BUT TRUST ME, BUSINESS IS
BOOMING.
SO I TAKE IT YOU'VE SEEN SOME OF
OUR WORK.
WHAT ARE SOME OF YOUR FAVORITES?
>> THE ONES ON YOUR WALL ARE ALL
CLASSICS.
CHARMIN, USE AFTER YOU POOP.
>> THEY PASSED ON THAT.
>> LEGO, BET YOU CAN'T EAT JUST
ONE.
>> THAT WAS A PASS THAT LATER
BECAME A LAWSUIT.
>> AND DORITOS 4D, OPEN WIDE.
I CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE IT'S NOT
YOUR ONLY AD FEATURING A PEA
NUS.
>> WE HAD TO BLUR THOSE.
>> YOUR WEBSITE ALSO SAYS YOU
INVENT MASCOTS FOR COMPANIES.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
YOU KNOW HOW PLANTERS HAS
MR. PEANUT?
WELL WE APPROACHED MAXWELL HOUSE
COFFEE ABOUT CREATING
MRS. MAXWELL.
>> AND YOU CHOSE GHISLAINE
MAXWELL, THE ASSOCIATE OF
JEFFREY EPSTEIN?
>> THAT'S WHAT MAXWELL HOUSE
SAID.
WELL, THEY YELLED IT AT OUR
LAWYER.
SHE'S EARLY.
TELL ME, WHY DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
MMM MATERIAL?
SORRY I STUTTERED.
>> I WORKED FOR SIX YEARS FOR
BBDO.
>> THAT'S A GREAT FIRM.
>> NO, BBDO IS A DATING APP.
BIG BEAUTIFUL DONGS ONLY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT APP.
>> I SAW THAT YOU GUYS WERE
LOOKING FOR AN ART DIRECTOR AND
I THOUGHT, WHAT'S THE HARM IN
APPLYING?
>> DID YOU BRING A PORTFOLIO?
>> I DID.
>> UPS GO FETCH AND HE'S
THROWING THE THE PACKAGE INTO
THE OCEAN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, IT GIVES YOU A
SENSE THE PACKAGES GO ALL AROUND
THE WORLD.
>> I LIKE HOW THE WAVES ARE
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> HERE'S ANOTHER ONE, IT'S THE
ALL-NEW CHEVY BOLT.
>> MOVE OVER USAIN BOLT, THERE'S
A NEW BOLT IN TOWN.
THE CAR IS RUNNING OVER USAIN
BOLT.
>> CUTS HIM IN HALF, THEN IT
LAUGHS.
THAT'S WHAT THE HA HA HA IS.
>> RIGHT.
I LOVE THAT DETAIL.
I'M GUESSING SO WILL CHEVY.
>> HERE'S ONE FOR EBAY.
AND AGAIN, SOME OF THE ART IS
TEMP.
>> EBAY, TOO BAD YOU CAN'T SELL
WOMEN ON THIS SITE, OR CAN YOU?
AND THEN THERE'S A LIGHT BULB.
>> TO SHOW THAT IT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
>> YOU'VE GIVEN US A LOT TO
THINK ABOUT.
BY US, I MEAN ME.
BY A LOT, I MEAN A LITTLE.
WHAT'S THAT LAST DRAWING YOU'VE
GOT IN THERE?
>> OH, IT'S NOTHING.
>> OH COME ON, LET ME SEE IT.
>> I SAID IT'S NOTHING.
>> AND I SAID LET ME SEE IT.
>> I GOT SOMETHING ELSE I'D
RATHER SHOW YOU.
>> SO WOULD I.
>> TAKE THAT.
>> STOP IT, YOU'LL KILL EACH
OTHER.
>> NOT BAD.
>> YEAH.
NOT BAD YOURSELF.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK YOU'VE EARNED THIS.
>> IT'S AN AD FOR NETFLIX.
IT'S PERFECT.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
AND NOW I THINK MY WORK HERE IS
DONE.
♪♪♪
>> HE TOOK MY HAT.
>> FORGET ABOUT YOUR HAT!
GET KEVIN NETFLIX ON THE PHONE
AND TELL HIM I'M ABOUT TO SAVE
HIS COMPANY.
>> NETFLIX, WE HAVE PORN NOW.